you lovely folks showed up for my week
late video on moon night i love you for
that i thank you for that we all proceed
with fingers crossed so they can keep
the quality up until you know the end
and before we continue our talk about
the fun and trivial i do want to thank
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by dr squatch still my
shower soap dr squash the ones changing
the way men approach hygiene with
products that make you look great smell
great without those harmful chemicals
some other soap companies cram into
their product and as i mentioned before
it's not just soap we also got shampoo
conditioner beard oil that's right pine
tar soap and crushed pine beard oil as i
found out last time i did the
sponsorship i'm not the only one who
loves to smell a pine i guess that's a
thing my people
bliss so click the link below and use my
promo code dsq jones and new customers
can get 20 off of your order of 20 or
more and thank you once again to dr
squatch for sponsoring this video i do
appreciate it and now another week
another episode of moon night moon night
the show where less is more
and more is definitely less which is
episode three now at the end of episode
two uh oscar isaac wakes up in egypt i
guess i gotta differentiate mark specter
oscar isaac wakes up in egypt you know
you see the egyptian pyramid so at the
beginning of this episode it's like mark
spector oscar isaac was going through
what other oscar isaac was going through
in the first couple episodes it's like
he's losing time and then people are
beating up and i was like ha not the
messer becomes the messy but it's not
really because other oscar isaac is
definitely not throwing down like that
the ancient egyptian bird god dicks
taking over he's killing people
otherwise known as getting his ass out
of hot water because it's it's not like
he's just taking over like oh sweet no
it's like mercenaries knives and guns
and all right gonna take over now gonna
get you out of this gonna get us out of
this now i gotta say oscar isaac in this
role by three episodes we've seen enough
to say he's actually great in this role
these roles kind of throws back to
willem dafoe and the original spider-man
where he's talking to himself in the
mirror just like he's so good at doing
that there's a scene where he's talking
to his reflection it's all one shot but
then you see the back of his head when
nice oscar isaac's talking i was like is
he just on the fly switching character
like that very few people can play both
solid snake and ottacon but he pulls it
off nicely in fact he's what keeps me
engaged with the role because i mean
granted it's only three episodes episode
three the weakest of the three i really
gotta go talk to this rich not menacing
at all philanthropist guy get their
hands on a map and action sequence goes
down and that's when i say less is more
with this show it's really funny how the
most interesting action sequences are
the ones you don't see guess that's a
testament to if you show the audience
less their brains will fill in the gaps
and they'll come up with something far
more interesting than a multi-billion
dollar studio cam just shows the power
of the human imagination that's just
what books are how many times have you
read a book then you watch the movie and
you're like i'd
just look cooler in my head so anytime
oscar isaac blacks out loses time and
he's holding a bloody knife and they're
just bodies around him i was like that's
amazing the show should just keep doing
that because as the action sequence goes
down in this episode i was like that's
just really dark it's hard to see it's
dimly lit not that there weren't cool
things in it you know when he was
getting stabbed and impaled i thought
that was great but this was the moment i
was like all right nice guy oscar isaac
you know when he takes control and he's
what is it mr knight he has the suit
that's how you can tell the difference
between the two and he just starts
getting stabbed and he was like nope
take it back and he gives it right back
to mark specter i was like
what good was that but the episode does
go on to show that that's not his
wheelhouse he is the brains mark specter
is the brawn i like the council of the
gods too all these egyptian gods in
their
human being avatar bodies and they're
all pretty much judging
bird dick what's his name conscious his
name is conjured and you know they're
all judging him i like that that's
intriguing stuff it makes me think all
right is congre really an [ __ ] or
does he have good reason to hate these
other gods don't give me that he kills
people he's an [ __ ] thing yeah sure
everyone who loves punisher but i am
getting tired of that in canon nmcu
excuse of we made a promise to stay out
of human affairs and that's why we do
that i feel like that is every mcu
writer's way of being like and that's
why they didn't interfere with thanos
and that's the downside of an expanding
cinematic universe that has characters
coming into it they never thought they
were gonna have come into it i mean when
you have a one glove six stone flying
pissed off purple homer snapping half of
the beings in existence
existence that's a really big problem
all the billions of galaxies it's
it's unfathomable i feel like that
should have been the moment that all the
mcu gods out there that sat that one out
probably should have been like yeah yeah
well just because it happened on earth
doesn't mean it's
earth [ __ ] granted an in-canon excuse as
to why all these cosmic mcu gods sat
that fight out probably should happen is
that the one they're giving it's a lazy
one but yeah so i like the council of
egyptian gods you know i thought that
was neat just seeing the structure of
how they do things so it's not even
that's like part of what stands out in
this episode the other stuff is the
celestial [ __ ] not that it happened
but
what were people's reactions to that
again another thing about this expanding
universe it's not like a trilogy where
these isolated events happen this is the
mcu man there's a lot of [ __ ] that's
happened to a lot of people so when they
see an eclipse just happen and that [ __ ]
was not scheduled like do they freak out
like oh my god it's happening it's
happening oh no no please please i'm
still here i didn't turn to ash oh
thank god well that was i thought it was
going to be crazy again just the moon
moving in strange ways but i'm still
here i call that a win
what's that all the coast cities are
flooding well
well that does suck psych now the sky is
doing this oh god [ __ ] i'm gonna turn to
ash
i don't know why that's what i got hung
up on by the end of this episode like
conscious stuck in this little chess
piece ethan hawks talking some mad [ __ ]
to this little statue with him in it and
i'm like god that must have freaked some
people out on earth look at the end guys
i'm having fun watching these episodes
having fun talking about them actually i
thought there's gonna be a show like and
that's why i binge that's why i prefer
to binge but i'm actually digging the
little snippets they give me every week
funny this show is most interesting when
it's
egyptian lore you have this guy this
character with at least two
personalities rattling around in there
this skexy skeleton egyptian god that
only he can see is talking to him
sometimes that god inhabits his body in
which it's just a blackout a splice
that's when this show is most
interesting to me but when it's moon
night in the suit fighting the baddies a
superhero show feeling like a superhero
show that's when it's least interesting
to me not that's ironic but is what it
is in any case i gotta bring this up
anytime they say the name layla is the
character that's mark spector's wife any
time someone says her name am i the only
one who thinks
[Music]
i can't be the only one tell me i'm not
the only one or so moon night episode
three have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you